hey
[Applause]
he's okay he's okay he's our brother
he's our brother man that bitch ain't
got nothing to do with me it's his first
wedding
back up first wedding back up back up
come here come here come here
come here
that's my motherfucking sister
get away from me
back up
back up back up
backwards
back up
back up
back up
back up
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
no i'm okay i'm all right all
all
right
get some water
need some water no i'm all right let me
get it out oh shit
hold on a second get a call no no no no
i'm all right i'm all right all right
man back up here
[Applause]
[Applause]
all
right what happened he struck him what
happened all right all right i'm okay
i'm all right i'm all right i'm all
right i'm all right
all right
what happened
here
what happened the guy knocked me out man
me out sit down
everybody back up
back up
back up sit down sit down
[Applause]
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah she's a no she's
a no she's a no she's a no
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
no i gotta i'm gonna stay with y'all man
i gotta chill take you to the hospital i
gotta stay with y'all man hospital
zero five zero oh shit man
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right i'm taking him to the hospital
i'm taking him to the hospital
started shot somebody go after my own
coffee shop okay
are you okay yeah i'm all right all
right
i'm sure i'm just taking them just in
case you've been hit by anything so i
said
the dude hit me man
you would he pointed me out man he
pushed me out okay no no you're going
you need to make sure he's okay i know
this i'm working all right
i'm just gonna run right now can you
breathe yeah i'm gonna breathe man okay
just be a little dizzy right yeah gonna
be okay though okay
hurry up we'll get there
get your feet in
get your feet in ah fuck get your feet
in hey hey we gotta stay here
nothing bro seriously bro you don't know
what happened we got to stay here man
please no please please please no no we
got to stop here man sorry we're good to
take you to the hospital we got to stay
here bro please were you shot no i
wasn't shocked how did you know that did
you hear a bang no
no he punched me out the dude punched me
out
he he knocked me out okay
he knocked me out
oh shit can you breathe yeah i can
breathe anywhere nah just for my head
just your head
he punched me in the face in the face
let me look look let me get a flashlight
shit there's someone to give me an
update ah damn
we gotta breathe
oh man
hey he just he just knocked you out yeah
he just knocked me out no he got no hold
on all right let's go help him cry yeah
all right
oh fuck
cause we're gonna have we're gonna need
crowd control wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait catch you bruh all right
all right are we here what's today's day
yeah today's the 20th the 20th yeah
no the days well if it's after midnight
what time is it it's the 19th okay yeah
are you good yeah i'm good i'm good
all right thanks mike thanks mike
yeah yeah yeah yeah
all
yeah i'm good
yeah we need to stay here
because this is going to be crazy
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
one person's
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
he knocked
come over here and talk to me come over
here talk to me relax
relax relax relax right because he's a
fucking dick no no stop stop please
please please please please thank you i
i came to thank you for helping me all
right i came to thank you for helping me
because you did thank you thank you
thank you thank you for watching me up
no no no no no no relax relax relax
relax
we're going to sleep in front of him i
don't know
right now where
ambulance
it's coming all right
all right when are they coming cece
do me a favor
we're just going to get dan bless to
come down here all right yeah i'm okay
all right i'm just dazed that's all i'm
good what do you want to do man come on
go ahead and do it
for this point on please please your man
did this
your man your man escalated please
please please please
thank you thank you please the police
i'm going to surprise you all right yeah
yeah
[Applause]
bro
why you think i'm over here talking to
you
get your man you came and helped me all
right
thank you okay
all right because it's not that serious
come on all right i'll be crazy for no
reason
all right
[Applause]
okay all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey where you want to you want to start
to start it where i'll let him get okay
take this whole area off now all right
anybody who's not
[Applause]
well he already knocked me out so you
were the second one
scene right now
hey
all right yeah inside please
regardless
of a wedding reception
[Applause]
if you can help us get everybody inside
that'd be a big help back inside
[Applause]
do me a favor can i ask you something
can i answer something if you want to do
that can you do that over there can you
do that over there for me please
do that over there
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
huh you went black for a couple